good morning believe nation today's
message is just do right over to you
Maya Angelou I have a painting by Phoebe
of a group that she calls histor
Sookie's funeral and they are the women
about nine women and they they all look
like women and my grandmother's prayer
meeting group so whenever I'm obliged to
do something I take that painting and I
look at that painting there's an empty
chair and I think now what would grandma
do what would she say I can almost hear
her voice say my sister you know was
right just do right you don't really
have to ask anybody the truth is right
may not be expedient it may not be
profitable but it will satisfy your soul
it brings you the kind of protection
that bodyguards can't give you
try to be all you can be to be the best
human being you can be try to be that in
your church and your temple try to be
that in your classroom do it because it
is right to do people wouldn't know you
and they will add their prayers to your
life they'll wish you well I think if
your name is mentioned and people say oh
hell oh damn
and then you doing something wrong but
if your name is mentioning people say oh
she's so sweet he's so nice oh and let
oh god bless her yeah yeah so try to
live your life in a way that you will
not regret years of useless virtue and
inertia and timidity take up the the
baffle take it up it's yours this is
your life this is your world I'll be
leaving it long before you under the
ordinary set of circumstances you make
your own choices you can decide life
isn't worth living and it would be the
worst thing you can do how do you know
so far try it see so pick it up pick up
the battling and make it a better world
just where you are yes and it can be
better and it must be better but it is
up to us I really love this message and
the only thing I would add to it is
believe that you can do right believe
that you can have an impact with the
knowledge that you have now in the
resources and the information and the
hustle and the heart and the drive and
the energy and the passion and the
wisdom that you have right now even
though it may not be what you think you
can have even though you may look up to
people and say well they have a lot more
resources than I do or they're a lot
smarter they have a lot more connections
than I do
it doesn't mean that you still can't do
right that you still can't have an
impact and yes the greater resources you
have and the greater abilities you have
I believe the greater responsibility you
have to try to make a bigger impact but
even if you have nothing zero you can
still give somebody a hug when they need
it
you can still commit your time to a
cause that you believe it you could
still give your energy your ideas your
creativity to something or someone that
is trying to make the world a better
place it starts with you believing that
you can believe in that you can make
that impact and not asking yourself the
question anymore well Who am I to do
that when you believe that you can make
an impact that's when you start actually
making a dramatic so the question today
today is I'm curious what is the right
thing that you are doing right now
what's the impact that you're having and
how are you doing right in the world
leave in the comments below
I will join in the discussion I also
wanted to give a quick shout out to
Jasmine Blake Jasmine thank you so much
for buying a copy of my book really
means a lot to me
those of you guys watching if you want
to change that a shout out in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book it's really good I promise you then
email in the receipt so we can keep
track and send you the bonuses thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events vessel
this prey so give me go